[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand Paris reine du monde lanc s r à
son époque de gloire vers les années 20
d'Amérique mis nous rabonis s grand
bêtes en chantant ils ont tout mais pas
ça aux
USA quand les Parisiennes portait des
bracelets jusque là quand le couturier
Poiret était vraiment le roi le
charleseston faisait rage en hispan au
elage le tout Paris se montrait allé des
acacia lorsque vien et dou s joué auf
sur le toit corquel m détail et la
violette c'était une ronde folle du Bal
à la coupole et du grand écart à
la closer des las les Dolly sister lanç
alors un nouveau pas et les danseurs de
tango luisant de
gomina en lançit les vieilles dame
l'ordonnant du vagalâ mais Paris était
la capitale de la
joie en traversant l'Atlantique pour la
première fois l'aviateur Lindberg était
accueilli comme un roi le brave
président d'merg au flegmatique Lindberg
disait venez dans bras petit
embrassez-moi quand Paris reine du monde
chantait
Valencia diagilev par s Balet et Vinc
l'opéra c'était vraiment une époque un
peu dingue un peu loufoque mais Paris
était reine du monde en ce
tempsl pourtant croyez-moi j'adore le
Paris
d'jourd'hui s'il n'y a plus d'Hispano il
y a des
Maseratis il y a à la pop musique et des
sonneau fantastiques un chanteur pour
ses début nous a montré son nu comme la
nouvelle mode s'inspire de
1920 et que Paris continue de lancer ses
refrains rien n'est changé à Paname les
TI les jolies femmes Paris pour lancer
la mode sera toujours premier et nous
savons que paris sera toujours
Paris
[Applaudissements]